hate speech and violent misinformation
hate hate speech is still widespread wow
you seem like a regular barrel full
laughs hey tasty tasty regulation
regulation try the fish ties my flour
squirts water what an absolute hack
here's the thing I actually I find John
Oliver funny and dangerously wrong I
want to know people if I'm alone G of
entertainers in the completely opposite
side of the political spectrum of whom
you're a die-hard fan can you separate
the art from the artist where does it
start to bleed in comment below I want
to know because this is the latest John
Oliver segment take down segment I guess
you call it you know what let's just
roll the clip and let's get into John
Oliver's latest takedown hate speech
against Muslims and especially the ROE
hinge er flourished oh here we go hosted
by military leaders and politicians as
well as prominent Buddhist monks like
Ashton where are two okay here we go so
this whole thing by the way it said this
whole video you watch a segment there's
kind of some jokes it seems sort of
irrelevant he's jumping from topic to
topic it's a lead-up he's talking about
what people hate most obviously Facebook
right then using the old bait and switch
to Islamophobia I was wondering where it
would come in so he goes on to talk
about this monk this is this is
important because I have to give you
context how hateful he is which is true
but is it unique this one Burmese monk
are there other people in setting
violence in social media and since we're
talking about Islamophobia niz islam
this is what's so important with it John
all of our segments yeah
actually Isis successfully spreads more
misinformation than any other suspended
accounts on Twitter before they get
banned those was actually comes from
Stanford funding as we've repeatedly
mentioned in the past Facebook does have
a legitimate problem with Islam ik
terrorist inciting violence but it's not
the focus of done in our segment know
the entirety of this segment is Isis
completely withheld it tonight
Islamophobia Isis gets mentioned guess
how many times zero zero not once and
steady drones on about this this monks
account with less than 400,000 followers
consider for a moment that Burma's
population is 53 million a Facebook page
with 300,000 followers was hardly
influential and by the way Facebook
banned it yeah so here's their job they
did their jobs here's what's funny Iowa
claims a problem is Facebook giving this
monk a platform but then he plays clips
and overlays and it turns up the monk is
actually on the cover of Time magazine
and interviewed on 60 minutes
Facebook fans the monk but left-wing
print TV the media they're probably fine
giving him a platform again there's
nothing wrong with being critical of the
monk but these the same people who claim
that Charles Marais should even be
allowed to speak or debate at university
because what Murray says it's hateful so
why allow this monk in 60 minutes if his
speech is really that dangerous
Otsu had hundreds of thousands of
followers on Facebook and he uses we
carry havoc including spreading false
accusations that a Muslim business owner
had raped a buddhist employee a post
that helped instigate riots in this
event mandalay which people were killed
and around 20 others injured and yet
despite repeated warnings about where
our to Facebook didn't get around to
banning him until earlier this year okay
so this is become this is not becoming
more and more clear yeah he spends seven
minutes making jokes about Facebook and
then again pointing out what most of us
hate about faith now he spends not more
than 30 seconds on any single top
because it what the what John Oliver
does so well he doesn't switch where he
just bounces around bounces around
bouncing and then all of a sudden the
entirety other the remainder is
Islamophobia and hate speech I was
watching a comedy show just talk about
the Care Bears and I was like
Islamophobia hates we just love it for
the rest of the video that's what this
is Islamophobia there it is well if that
monk is responsible for people dying
shouldn't we call the cops instead of
calling Facebook yeah I roll the dice
and I give Zuckerberg back John Oliver
equates hate speech with incite inciting
violence and there are two very very
different things but let's go to the
next clip first so how did so much hate
speech and violence inciting content
stay up for so long because it's not
like Facebook doesn't have rules they
have a lot of them hate speech there
this is so telling to me a comedian
flippantly using the term hate speech
like it's a real thing I don't know
about is this not just bone-chilling
least scary to you when a comedian just
you determine hate speech and throws it
out there so we all we all it like there
isn't even a debate on the idea of hate
speech or restrictions in the First
Amendment past the First Amendment to of
course yeah we all great a speech now
how does facebook enforced hate speech
laws they look to target and censor and
and it's something else that's really
scary to me like you said he says hate
speech and incitement to violence I
demons two very different things
according to to is moving the goalposts
in a very dangerous way all of a sudden
a joke becomes a human rights violation
right yeah yeah right I think the only
thing that's dangerous is when it
incites violence people say incitement
of violence it's not like hey I can't
stand Muslims and Burma and someone goes
her orders god Facebook's doesn't like
move them so Elmo shoot you you didn't
violence inciting violence is hey listen
I will I will reward you if you go and
harm that person yang someone to put a
hit out on somebody else or telling
people to go forward and actually commit
an act of violence proactively we need
to be really clear about what a night
minute of Iowans is like hey punch him
in the face for no reason other than
he's Canadian that's a hold on does a
crime is that what you invited me to
Texas punches you in the face because I
happen to say that I don't like
Canadians yeah
and they find out they are one that's
not my fault it's them yeah all right
next you can quibble you can absolutely
quibble with where Facebook draws its
lines and the broader discussion of
private companies policing speech is an
important one but the point is Facebook
does have standards that are enforced in
a number of ways you quibble now it's
not a quibble speech is a central debate
of our time where you line up on the
ideas of speech transparency
inconsistency will tell us exactly who
you I can tell you this when someone
gives you their opinion on freedom of
speech or the First Amendment when
someone tells you where they line up
with that fundamental worldview I can
almost invariably tell you where they'll
end up on every single other fundamental
issue of our time it is an absolute
litmus test yeah
it's foundational for everything the
First Amendment is I know now suddenly
sounds like some cockney guy who bought
a big poker yeah it's exactly what it's
just what I don't like him and I know
that would piss him off even more than
giving him the benefit of his London
accent all right next clip hate speech
is language specific okay all right
listen let's just not let's just just to
save you guys some time okay let's just
show you we have a montage to show you
how many times he references hate speech
on ironically in the video let's just
roll that so we don't keep coming back
to it yeah viral rumors and hateful
comments on Facebook have speech against
Muslims for those seeking to spread hate
speech and violence misinformation hate
hate speech is still widespread wow you
seem like a regular barrel full laughs
don't you this is a regulation trying to
finish ties what an absolute hack going
to a show with this guy I don't know
what would he talk about one time and
you're done and does he does he does he
then berate people who are politically
correct who moan if he says something
it's offensive how do you how do you
have a light - stainer that's always
funny to me when you see these
self-professed
sort of progressive liberal comedians
yeah and they tell a joke in the
audience moans like oh quit being so
sensitive you're the one who told them
to be because of living in the hell you
created and joy
it's like Orange County now there this
is nobody's fault it's a notification
bill because subscriptions don't only
mean anything on YouTube anymore and
apparently you might not even be
notified if you subscribe so it the
notification Bell join welcome for The
Daily Show 6 mend our students veteran
active military ok let's go to the next
clip you can get mad I don't believe the
Holocaust happened Oh yikes
can someone please explain to me why
what Charlie Rose did was so wrong I
wouldn't post that but you can George
Soros invented mosquitoes Hillary
Clinton created aids yeah okay so
usually I should explain the context
before he goes is this fake Facebook ad
you know that he's presenting and listen
it's it starts with Facebook being full
of bull crap absolutely okay we
understand that I think everybody agrees
half-truths and lies here yeah or as the
coop to turn to the left invented as we
know what fake news but again the
sleight of hand of somebody host people
don't notice so he takes what most of us
joke about with Facebook than segues
into politics but the only political
points that you see there conspiracy
theories presented are not only radical
it almost never actually expressed by
the way actually I don't think I've ever
heard anyone say that George Soros
invented mosquito probably Hillary
Clinton I understand they're using
extreme example to make a point for
comedy okay I don't wanna get I'm gonna
about that if we if we want to consider
this comedy but if you look at it the
theories you know that they are the
entirely target and Lampoon suppose it
right-wingers how about peppering in
some Donald Trump peeing on prostitutes
conspiracies no anti-fog conspiring
against the 1% no about pointing out the
absurdity of the Cavanaugh allegations
no
pointing out the politifact waffles
knobs who have been caught repeatedly
lying there misleading or outright
dishonest pretty no we're not gonna talk
about any of those things
okay so again just beware the sleight of
hand here it's just comedy but you only
do it from one point of view always
that's fine if you just tell your
audience about it you hack next clip
Facebook disgusting using with this clip
I think all of us agree Facebook is
misleading it really is a dumpster fires
are related don't serve fires it relates
to information I'm in America I've felt
that way since 2016 when the Gizmodo
article leaks that Facebook moderators
were selectively censoring specific
conservative pages including yours truly
yeah so I'm feeling this way for a long
time you're on that list but back then
from the left not a peep it's also
engine that self-professed comedians
like John Oliver spend so much time just
making these place two giant
corporations to control and police
speech but when an actual abuse of free
speech occurs like say with Mike Ward
here being put before human rights
tribunal for a joke
not a peep did you ever come to your
defense no he didn't know what make a
video about you that wasn't funny he was
spending too much time on this monk with
300,000 fans apparently almost almost
monk stole my thunder remember the term
fake fake news was actually invented by
the left after Trump was elected it was
designed as a tool to target Donald
Trump and then it backfired when Trump
used it against them now why could it
possibly be here's one thing that's just
crazy to me about the John Oliver
situation okay so you're bitching about
social media and like you said we all
watch this on social media but what's
the alternative ABC NBC CBS CNN it's
entirely left leaning on social media
the right is comparatively speaking
doing pretty well compared to
traditional media of course doesn't
there's a ton of crap on Facebook from
both the left in the right and I readily
admit and I tell we tell the viewers
often to not get your news from Facebook
yeah okay what would mr. John Facebook
needs to control hate speech Oliver have
as an alternative make an ABC CBS the
trend you see with John Oliver and it
bothers me is that nearly every single
takedown video he does is a plea for
more government control think about this
for second this is a comedian who's made
it his his mission he's in a zone that
is to put more control of your life in
the hands of the government at every
single turn
find me one video find me one single
segment or any any idea where John
Oliver consistency consistently is
advocating for more freedom not less
this is what's crazy to me none this is
the first generation not only of people
but comedians who are advocating for
less freedom of speech crazy bills yeah
has anybody looked down the road at how
this story ends
no comedians that's how it ends they
will they will have a poster of Lenny
Bruce up on their wall and then talk
about needing the police speech yeah
exactly
I guess we're gets right we found it
guess where I found this video on
YouTube hey you think outside of this
general sort of authoritarian plea from
John Oliver he never provides any
solutions never of course not
it's said it's just you know so there's
someone else to do something that's what
it is it is usually the case flipped
that somebody is the government and
something is more control over your life
so yeah listen fake news is a real
problem on social media again both the
right and the left
how can you guard against it we want to
offer some solutions here let's Crider
and I've said this quite a few times
create a news and media list yourself
don't rely on Facebook set bookmarks and
favorites and for every single
right-wing source have a left-wing
source so for example I say hit the
notification bell in this channel
because subscriptions don't mean
anything
the very next show you watch should be
John Oliver's or Vox or The Young Turks
I don't care just like whichever one you
can handle for the most amount of time
get a beer put Fox News in your newsfeed
great next needs to be HuffPo Breitbart
next one needs to be slate do it
yourself curate a news feed where you
have right left right left right left
and avoid any news sites by the way
claiming to be unbiased like CNN or
Washington Post it's impossible they're
almost always lying to you get both
sides of every single story and you'll
be more educated than 99% of the
population tell everyone else who's
watching this to try doing the same not
only will you be more educated but hey
it didn't require sweeping government
censorship for corporate speech control
sorry John Oliver ain't that a [ __ ] hey
there YouTube viewer you like Samantha B
of course not because you've actually
made it to this end card you are a
miracle of the Internet I would say
subscribe or hit the notification button
but I don't really know what that means
on YouTube you might not get notified
anyway but you can join up at laterthe
credit calm slash mug club that's monk
with this wonderful hand edge mug and
you get to watch not only clips but the
full one-hour Daily Show every single
day that was redundant because I said
daily but every single day
we're gonna keep it anyway because we
shoot these end cards a whole lot in one
afternoon we're scraping the bottom of
the barrel with this one